bonjour manuel valls joue beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
vous êtes évidemment c'est un premier
ministre auteur du livre les mots
lentilles républicain cette édition de
l'observatoire et on va bien sûr parler
de cette campagne présidentielle on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes prenez
intervient en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
gêne y'a les piliers de la voix du nord
quand genia bonjour yann bonjour
monsieur valls bonjour et manuel valls
emmanuel macron a donc réuni hier soir
les états partenaires européens et
africains pour faire un point sur le
dispositif français au sahel il devrait
acter le retrait des troupes du mali un
redéploiement dans la région aujourd'hui
on constate au mali un retour des
djihadistes et même de nouveau contre
pied à distribuer de nouveaux groupes
terroristes qui voit le jour l'opération
elle a été déclenchée en 2013 à
s'appeler serval à l'époque elle est
devenue barca n'a été déclenchée par
françois hollande est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous diriez que c'est un échec voire un
fiasco non non parce que sans
l'intervention de 2013 sans la présence
des soldats français de partenaires
européens et africains qui les
accompagnait aujourd'hui le mali serait
un état démembrer ou dans les mains des
terroristes
en revanche je crois que la france et
ses partenaires ont raison tirer les
conséquences de la situation politique
malienne suite à deux coups d'état à une
junte dont on voit bien qu'elle est dans
une logique d'affrontement avec la
france en revanche je crois ce qui est
très important c'est que d'une manière
ou d'une autre on verra quelle est la
nature des annonces la france soit
présente dans ce sel parce qu'il en va
de la sécurité de nos partenaires dans
des pays nous savons qu'ils sont
fragiles d'un point de vue politique
économique avec des défis démographiques
notamment tout à fait considérable pour
assurer leur sécurité mais pour assurer
aussi dans notre sécurité
je crois que c'est la logique des
décisions qui vont être prises même si
c'est difficile mais si moi je considère
toujours qu'il faut garder non seulement
une présence mais une capacité d'action
rapide sur les cessions rapide c'est
vrai qu'on parle d'eux par exemple de la
force takouba qui est une force spéciale
qui est plus réduite que l'opération
barkan est ce que c'est de ça dont vous
parlez oui oui je pense est là je suis
ne suis pas au gouvernement ce sont des
sujets délicats
si moi je me rappelle de l'effet d'abord
de l'opération de la décision courageuse
de françois hollande de l'opération
technique et militaire qui avait été
saluée par tous monnaies notamment par
nos partenaires mais aussi celui de se
laver signifié en termes d'image pour la
france sur le continent africain un
retrait mais ce n'est pas l'option qui
va être choisi retrait brutal un retrait
de l'afrique sonnerait comme un signe de
de désertion ce serait un signe très
très négatif dans lequel nous nous
voyons et en plus dans nous sommes dans
un monde ouvert dans lequel d'autres
s'infiltre on voit bien et quand est-ce
que c'est pas au travers de cette de ce
retrait du mali ce que c'est pas
finalement apte et la victoire de la
russie qui intervient sous la forme de
deux mercenaires wagner la ligne de
crête elle est étroite donc mon pauvre
si si nous nous retirons du mali pour
des raisons politiques que chacun a bien
en tête le rôle l'attitude scandaleuse
delà de la junte il ne faut pas donner
en même temps le signe d'un abandon d'un
retrait de nos partenaires loyaux des
populations africaines par rapport à nos
intérêts stratégiques dont de la ligue
dans la ligne et est ligne de crête est
extrêmement étroite je le répète tam en
face à des attitudes à des groupes de
mercenaires nous parlons du groupe
wagner qui sont là notamment voyons
notamment dans d'autres pays en
centrafrique qui sont là pour piller
aussi des ressources et pour ceux se
payer sur eux sur la bête mais d'autant
manuel valls que plus de 50 de nos
soldats français sont morts là bas et ça
évidemment ça touche les français si on
se retire aujourd'hui du magny alors que
les groupes terroristes
ils sont encore présents est ce que ça
peut pas donner l'impression que
finalement il ya eu 50 morts pour rien
non ça je le sais c'est insupportable à
entendre ce serait insupportable
d'ailleurs entendre j'écoutais ce matin
le les mots très très sensible très
courageux d'un ancien sénateur jean
marie bockel qui a perdu son fils là bas
non ce sont des héros ce sont des
soldats des hommes et des femmes que je
connais bien je suis allé plusieurs fois
les les rencontrer sur surplace nom est
une façon il ya un moment où les où les
houlé les troupes françaises n'ont pas
vocation à rester dont je peux y ait une
situation objective mais il faut que la
france reste dans la région et la
capacité d'intervenir d'autant plus si
nous considérons que ces terroristes là
non seulement s'attaque aux africains
aux états africains mais mais s'attaque
aussi à nos intérêts stratégiques corps
une fois dans une situation très fragile
je vous rappelle qu'il ya eu
trois quatre coups d'état non dans la
région en afrique de l'ouest
oui également puisque moscou a donné
quelques signes plutôt favorable avec un
retrait partiel de deux de ses troupes
alors d un retrait qui n'est pas
constatée par par l'otan pas confirmé
non plus par le ministre jean yves le
drian est ce qu'on peut faire encore
confiance à vladimir poutine doit il
faut poursuivre le dialogue
moi je salue le déplacement du chef de
l'état du président de la république
ce dialogue j'imagine compliqué
difficile sans doute parfois brutale
avec vladimir poutine a été utile pour
vous est ce qu'ils sont il faut
dialoguer tu peux pas y avoir une
rupture du dialogue qu'il faut être
lucide nous ne savons pas au fond ce que
veut la diminuer le chancelier
d'allemagne aussi le la rencontre et 7
cette semaine donc je pense qu'avec nous
devons avoir un objectif nous les
européens c'est c'est d'assurer nous
l'espérons le plus rapidement possible
la mise en oeuvre d'un pacte je dirais
de stabilité et de sécurité pour
l'europe parce que tout cela se passe en
europe mais je crois que rien n'est joué
le sentiment d'une forme de désescalade
tant mieux mais rien n'est joué mais
nous voyons bien les inquiétudes qui
n'est certes ou paradoxe de ce dossier
c'est compris pour vladimir poutine
c'est que cela a remis en jeu d'une
certaine manière l'alliance atlantique
le rôle des américains sur place la
possibilité pour des pays comme la suède
et la finlande de demander leur entrée
dans l'alliance atlantique et de l'autre
côté il me semble que le degré attentifs
au fait que ne pourront pas être
suiviste ne pourront pas être non plus à
la remorque des états unis donc les
initiatives des manuels mâcon comme de
l'affichage de chancelier allemand vise
me semble-t-il a rappelé que c'est à
l'europe et aux dirigeants européens de
définir une stratégie est donc de
dialoguer avec l'adie mur poutine sans
naïveté et en sachant que à chaque fois
jean yves le drian le rappelait encore
il ya au sénat
tout dérapage est possible
oui sur la crise sanitaire on a assisté
donc à la vous allègement des mesures et
olivier vers on évoque la fin du masque
l'allègement du pass vaccinale mi mars
est-ce que c'est pas quand même un
calendrier qui vous interroge étant
donné que certains disent voilà on est à
proximité de l'élection présidentielle
étonnamment on nous parle de
d'allègement de mesure l'élection
présidentielle la journée entendu avant
par les jeux
goût des jeux on peut le penser on peut
dire tu as un peu de malice
non non parce que soyons réalistes c'est
quand même depuis le début
c'est le virus est là qu vie de 19 sont
différents variant qui amène à
l'adaptation au changement des
politiques sanitaires quand nous
regardons autour de nous
danemark espagne etc
ils sont en train d'alléger de manière
très très volontariste l'ensemble des
dispositifs donc donc je pense qu'on va
vers des allègements et tant mieux de
l'autre côté il faut rester prudent sur
les gestes barrières
heures sur la nécessité de continuer à
vacciner les populations et puis surtout
pour le reconnaître nous ne savons pas
s'ils ne pourront pas faire face à
d'autres types de deux variants je crois
que le ministre de la santé lui-même a
évoqué des possibilités pour l'été
prochain donc il faut maintenir des
dispositifs existants c'est le cas du
pass sanitaire qui veut peut être amené
à rectifier d'une manière ou d'une autre
évidemment je ne je ne ferai pas je
n'espère pas de valse quelque chose
qu'ils ne sachent pas la différence des
mesures sanitaires c'est la dette
publique vous avez certainement vu que
la cour des comptes avait rendu son
rapport jusqu'à encore une fois à l'orée
de la présidentielle je pense que ça
boit ça fera cause et elle s'est accrue
de 560 milliards elle a explosé durant
le plat la crise sanitaire est ce que ça
nous prépare à des très mauvaises
nouvelles dans les futures années je ne
sais pas d'abord cette dette publique
elle s'est allégé pour tous les pays de
l'union européenne
bien évidemment quand marie va se
retirer les pays vont se retrouver dans
la situation antérieure tels que par
exemple l'allemagne aura évidemment en
termes de déficit public et de dette une
situation bien meilleure que la nôtre ce
qui en termes de compétitivité
évidemment lui donnera toujours le même
avantage que le connaissons mais nous
sommes face à un paradoxe il y a
incontestablement ce défi des déficits
publics et de la dette une partie vont
être rattrapés fort heureusement pas le
retour à la croissance de croissance
puissante mais ça ne suffira pas ça ne
suffira pas mais nous avons aussi besoin
d'investissements puissant on va pas
supprimer les postes de fonctionnaires à
l'hôpital dans la police dans la
gendarmerie mais dans les arrêts de
la cour des comptes joutes totalement
son rôle bien évidemment mais il
non mais il y alla de toute façon des
services publics puissants il ya une
demande et d'ailleurs eu un retour de
demande forte de l'état protecteur est
alors née des services une fait ensuite
on a mis ensuite nous avons besoin
d'investissements publics mais il est
vrai aussi privé massif puissant par le
spatial emmanuel macron parlé hier dans
la recherche dans l'innovation vendée
contient un plan et moi je m'en réjouis
qui a été annoncée de soutien et même de
retour de la filière nucléaire
construire des repères dans les 20 30
ans qui viennent là aussi ce sont des
investissements publics
et oui c'est une bonne question et donc
je pense que ça devrait être un des
débats de l'élection présidentielle et
des années qui viennent c'est comment on
réforme l'état pour le rendent
évidemment c'est pas nouveau est ce que
je dis est le plus efficace possible
mais je pense que nous allons vivre
pendant un certain temps avec cette
contradiction un état protecteur des
investissements puissant pour l'avenir
et la gestion de cette dette et ses
déficits depuis la cram et
je pense que les choix qui ont été faits
par la france et donner un années pour
faire face à la crise et que la crise
économique liée bien sûr au co vide soit
où sont des choix qui ont été justes
c'est là où le politique sert moi je je
voulais la cour des comptes dit c'est
pas que ça oui mais les choyer oco vite
j'ai aussi des choix structurelles qui
ont été faits qui du coup est idiot
depuis longtemps sans doute y compris
quand pierre moscovici était ministre de
l'économie entre 2012 et 2014 mais
l'europe aussi a fait des choix
importante ce que je crois c'est qu'on
ne peut pas n'y aura pas de retour à une
brutalité budgétaire si si si si demain
le sait on va écouter on
supprime des postes de fonctionnaires on
ferme des lits d'hôpitaux on ferme des
hôpitaux notamment fini je pense que
c'est assez fier le couple mais ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on n'est pas une
réflexion générale et je vais prendre un
exemple bien précis c'est tout notre
système de protection sociale qui sans
doute doit être revue et nous savons
bien que pour financer aussi ce système
de protection sociale il faudra prendre
des mesures difficiles mais nécessaires
par exemple sur les retraites et que une
mesure d'âge même si vous l'a toujours
pensé au carré en longues à ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt aux questions
de pénibilité les mesures d'âge sera
d'une manière ou d'une autre
oui mais depuis pariant où vit plus
longtemps pour vous aujourd'hui c'est 62
63 ans il ya les 42 annuités mais qui
continue à évoluer sans doute il faudra
aller sur 63 64 sur les missions du
monde le travail de la réforme tous
absolument essai de réformes d'ailleurs
vous voyez bien que y compris des choix
qui ont été faits quand j'étais au
gouvernement comme j'étais promises sont
des choix qui qui étaient justifiées qui
était juste et qu'il faudra continuer à
appliquer mais on voit bien qu'on aura
besoin de sept mesures d'âge et sans
doute de réformes plus profondes de nos
systèmes de protection sociale et on va
parler de la présidentielle vous êtes
engagés dans cette campagne engagée
contraire exelmans vous publier ce livre
eric zemmour lanthier république alors
on a bien compris de mettre contraire
examen et qui soutenez vous la
république et la france le parc bordé
qui porte la république et la france
mais je pense que l'un le sujet majeur
de cette élection présidentielle au delà
de ce que notre était déjà problème
stratégique
géostratégique et les problèmes liés à
nos finances publiques c'est comment
nous réconcilions les français avec eux
mêmes et avec leur institution et avec
la démocratie c'est tout le paradoxe
nous sommes un pays puissant qui compte
dont on attend la parole du président
sur le conflit entre l'ukraine et la
russie ou sur ce qui se passe en afrique
de l'ouest au au sel nous avons une
économie qui nous a permis de soutenir
les entreprises et les ménages quand
même incroyable avec des différences
significatives par rapport à des pays
voisins et nous sommes aussi un pays
fracture est divisée avec une violence
ça existe dans d'autres pays
démocratiques mais avec une violence
verbale et physique en parlait souvent
notamment vis-à-vis des élus ou de ceux
qui incarnent l'autorité policiers
gendarmes sapeurs-pompiers professeur
qui est particulièrement inquiétante
donc la question de l'unité de
l'apaisement de la maine de comment on
gouverne comme on réforme retraites
nucléaire de finances publiques c'est la
question fondamentale donc moi je ne
sais pas trop emmanuel macron s'est
engagé à résorber en 2017 s'il échoue il
est aussi un échec des manuels mâcon et
nous savons tous que c'était très
difficile c'est évidemment celui ci il
n'en est pas le seul responsable c'est à
dire que les autres responsables
politiques beaucoup aidé à au climat
politique mais oui c'est son échec donc
je pense que nouvelle candidature mais
le maquereau présentes qui semble être
semble-t-il le cas doit viser plus des
réformes nécessaires pour notamment à la
question l'école ou des retraites j'y
reviens c'est la réconciliation c'est
l'unité c'est la concorde en un mot à la
mode
indispensable si on veut pas dire qu'on
n'oublie pas par exemple les questions
de sécurité la lutte contre l'islamisme
de remettre à plat nos politiques
migratoires ne me séduit sujet à la fois
difficile et qui tendent nous le savons
bien la société mais c'est là dessus
aussi que moi je me déterminerai
quels examens fait sa campagne notamment
sur cette question de l'immigration vous
le voyez les dents
de campagne elle remplit les salles il
est assez haut dans les sondages est ce
que c'est aussi parce que les gens au
pouvoir dont vous n'avez pas répondu à
ses inquiétudes pour les dans son livre
jeudi il se nourrit de nos échecs de
nous manque que nous l'acheter une
partie de la gauche mariveraine le lac
était l'ami jean marie le pen comme les
populistes en géant kamel daoud grant
intellectuels algériens quand il pas
islamiste en algérie rappelle qu'ils se
sont nourries aussi geler les populistes
ont toujours excellent pour
photographier ce qui ne va pas leurs
solutions sont évidemment beaucoup plus
dangereux donc il suffit
d'énoncer moralement politiquement eric
zemmour ou marine le pen il faut
répondre aux questions nous allons
traiter notamment je pense qu'il faut
remettre à plat tous les politiques
migratoires et mémé mais c'est vrai
qu'en plus dans cette crise politique
morale que nous vivons tous personnages
des rup tiff qui qui qui ne sort pas de
la vie politique les zemmour est un
journaliste et polémiste comme on dit
donc les gens lui accorde une attention
parce qu'il n'est pas un politique mais
salle de bain il faut pas le combat sur
les manipulations les mensonges de
l'histoire qui met en plus au service
d'un projet qui est ce qu'il appelle lui
la bonification des droites c'est à dire
en finir avec ce cordon sanitaire qui a
toujours existé entre la droite et
l'extrême droite et moi je je je d'une
certaine manière je crie ce matin si je
peux dire je demande à la droite
républicaine
plus qu'honorable elle pécresse est une
femme de très grande qualité je dis vous
ne pouvez pas donner le moindre
sentiment sur le fait que vous ces 10,1
pouces à l'extrême droite elle a fait
dimanche selon vont hisser en tout cas
elle est là elle a ouvert une brèche un
débat qu'elle a cherché à combler mais
il ya des mots je pense français
papilles pour intervention c'est une
expression connoté du 10ème siècle qui
s'adressait notamment aux juges qu'ils
ne seraient pas français nous faut faire
très attention sur tous ces sujets là la
force de la droite républicaine celle
que celle de chirac notamment ça a été
de jamais céder le moindre pouce au
peuple et qu'on répond pas aux questions
sécurité immigration sentiment
d'ailleurs de perte de l'omi de la
france d'une forme de deux ouïes de de
décadence pour certains de
auquel je ne crois pas je combats
notamment cette idée dans dans ce livre
mais il faut répondre à cette idée de
déclassement social ou politique mais
sans céder le moindre pouce sur les
valeurs ne peut pas dire par exemple au
deuxième tour si d'aventuré valérie
pécresse ni accéder pas ce qui serait
terrible je crois pour la droite
républicaine avoir de nouveau la moindre
hésitation parce que d'ici at il enfin
d'après d'après le canard enchaîné non
mais c'est ce que eric ciotti avait
libre publiquement ça serait là une
faute morale et politique qui achèverait
définitivement la droite républicaine
après que le les bouleversements de 2017
est mis à terre la gauche sociale de
mobiles en difficulté à l'heure actuelle
pour obtenir ses parrainages il annule
d'ailleurs en déplacement à la réunion
pour essayer de les avoir est ce que
pour vous ce serait anormal car exelmans
n'est pas ses parrainages ne puisse pas
concourir oui monsieur mais les aura
approuvé les on vous avait dit fin
janvier que vous étiez prêt à travailler
avec macron ou pécresse est-ce que alors
moi j'avoue que dans ces cas-là ce jeu
je me pose la question de la de la
rigidité doctrinale de la colonne
vertébrale de monsieur valls est ce
qu'on peut comme ça indifféremment
travail est bon emmanuel macron et
valérie pécresse mais vu comme ça ça
fait deux mois à l'opportuniste
oui ou non mais parce que quoi qu'il
arrive le président aulas président la
public plaçons dans ces deux hypothèses
à travers votre question sera élu au
pire avec 16 17% premier tout au mieux
23%
et il obtiendra je pense du manioc de
l'autre une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale sur la base d'une abstention
massive ce qui leur pose je pense un
vrai problème démocratique de légitimité
du parlement en tout cas de l'assemblée
nationale de ce que je dis c'est que les
grandes forces politiques non pas dans
une même majorité dans un même
gouvernement devront s'entendre sur un
pacte républicain une union sacrée une
forme d'union sacrée pour reprendre un
mot de clemenceau sur un certain de
dossiers sur une période finances
publiques europe mesures d'âge sur les
retraites choix du nucléaire au fond la
république en marche emmanuel macron les
républicains une partie des socialistes
sont d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut
soutenir la filière nucléaire y compris
parce que derrière il ya également
l'enjeu de notre force de dissuasion
bien toute une filière où technologies
innovations sont indispensables en plus
d emplois que cela représente et surtout
dans dans ce moment où notre autonomie
en matière énergétique à nous renvoie
d'ailleurs au conflit les tensions entre
l'ukraine et la russie bon donc là sur
ces sujets là moi je disais moi je suis
prêt à aider à soutenir tous ceux qui
vont dans ce sens sur ces sujets j'ai
appelé à voter emmanuel macron pas coûté
cher hein je crois en 2017 aux premier
et deuxième tours j'ai été député
pendant un an de la majorité
présidentielle je serai pas
parlementaire
le jeu j'attends que manuel mâcon
rentrer en campagne qui ce sur un sujet
qui se et qui est qu'ils s'engagent je
le trouve d'ailleurs vu j'ai beaucoup
c'est le côté ancien premier ministre et
un club assez assez fermé mais je ne me
retrouve pas me d'entendre ce que dit
aussi jean pierre raffarin de ce point
de vue là moi j'attends la déclaration
des peuples mâcon après les uns les
autres s'engageant le jeu chacun connaît
la laïcité on sait que c'est un sujet
vous suivez particulièrement hier au
sénat y avait un débat sur le fait
d'interdire les signes religieux dans
les compétitions sportives la droite
sénatoriale voulait l'interdire le
gouvernement s'y oppose et ce cas des
ambiguïtés des manuels mâcon sur ce
sujet en tout cas je pense que ce sujet
là comment le dire le en même temps et
est impossible alors après je jeu
n'étant pas naïfs ayant un peu
d'expérience je vois bien aussi à quoi
servent les débats actuels des amendes
mandroux l'aspect constitutionnel n'est
pas forcément vérifiables détention des
débats mais je vais vous dire mon
sentiment je suis favorable à cette idée
interdiction des signes religieux
d'ailleurs on a vu qu'il y avait eu
aussi un débat au sein du gouvernement
j'ai trouvé des positions par exemple de
morlanne choc de marlène schiappa sur ce
jugement était parti en clair mais face
à une provocation au fait qu'on
l'islamisme testent la république il
faut être extrêmement ferme et notamment
vis-à-vis aussi de la condition des
femmes puisque ce voile lequel on veut
couvrir les cheveux d'une femme c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui de montain
du inacceptable
oui bien sûr alors vous avez entendu
comme comme moi les déclarations de
ségolène royal qui dit gentiment qu'est
la place lagny d'algos elle arrêterait
des mots gentiment qui fit qui vous a
frappé je vois jeu wii wheel alors
qu'elle n'a pas dit c'est moi qui la
fuit comme ça mais est ce que vous
auriez la même gentillesse à l'égard
d'amd d'anne hidalgo j'ai pas la même
gentillesse que ségolène royal c'est je
le jeu vous l'accord bon c'est une femme
libre elle elle se détermine comme
longtemps et de ce point de vue là il
faut le il faut le respecter elle a été
elle-même candidate à l'élection
présidentielle ce qui m'a frappé dans
les propos qu'elle tenait hier c'est que
i au fond c'était l'union pour l'union
plutôt elle elle disait jean luc
mélenchon mais une bonne campagne il est
devant dans les sondages il faut unir et
donc il faut qu anne hidalgo se retire
mais où elles font où sont les
convictions je pense que le vote utile à
gauche et jean luc mélenchon s'il part
la gestion mais sur quel projet mais sur
quel projet moi moi j'avais parlé des
gauches irréconciliables donc vous
pouvez imaginer quelle est ma ma réponse
c'est totalement incompatible nucléaire
sur leurs offres sont à la vision du
monde sur la laïcité par les ambiguïtés
évidemment de la france insoumise que
jean luc mélenchon et du talent qui mène
une campagne
très professionnelle pour reprendre le
mot de ségolène royal qu'il ait du monde
dans ses meetings qui soit un orateur
hors pair ça je vous la corne fois
écouteront quand même ce qui dit sur le
fond et l'union pour l'union ça ne
marche pas d'ailleurs c'est une erreur
on additionnerait pas d'ailleurs les les
électeurs mais s'il peut y avoir des
électeurs de gauche qui à la fin se
disent vous écouter on votera pour celui
qui est le mieux placé mais ça
n'arrangera rien au problème de la
gauche il n'a jamais été aussi faible
dans le pays et qui pour le moment en
tout cas totalement hors jeu
le ps va disparaître de deux petites
questions le ps va disparaître selon
vous oui mais je l'avais dit je pense
que le parti socialiste qui ne pas dire
ses idées ou ses élus n'existe pas mais
la marque socialiste ou socialisme est
totalement dépassée ne veut plus rien
dire la marque est finie c'est ainsi il
faudra reconstruire quelque chose
d'autre mais tu ne peut pas se faire à
partir de ce qui restera du parti c'est
ma dernière question évidemment vous
êtes à l'heure actuelle un grand
observateur de la vie politique mais est
ce que vous avez envie de redevenir
acteur et peut-être lors des
législatives prochaines non je ne crois
pas parce que je déjà fait mais oui
participer au débat
d'avoir un jour la possibilité d'avoir
de nouveau des démissions pour servir
mon pays mais ça ne dépend pas de moi
mais de façon je pense que ce n'est pas
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est ce que
devient cette cette grande démocratie
qui est la france qui est traversée par
par des fractures qui m'inquiète et
qu'il faut résoudre
à arrêter notre invité au rappel le
titre devait être lisez mon lentilles
républicain c'est aux éditions
l'observatoire
[Musique]